tu es l'un des crânes dégarnis les plus
connus de france non mais c'est vrai et
tu es un des mecs qui a le plus de
succès avec le genre de crâne c'est vrai
que ça devient hyper bien on va vous
noterez des sommets de crâne
a vous de me dire si c'est franck
gastambide faisait pas froid alors je
participe à ce grand combat france bien
sûr tu participes attention franck ou
pas franck regardez c'est le banh tet
franco patron frank 3e dan franck tu dis
quoi ces idoles zidane
j'en regarde on regarde énoncé fabrice
wii mc franks assez attention travail
trancou pas franck forte d'al aridha
gippingen safran qu un sou lice n'ont
regardé c'était been désert donc là pour
l'instant
c'est facile pour toi la tension franco
pantalon je suis monsieur preuve je vous
pensais pas du tout c'est zidane
non c'est qui ça zidane s'était dit dan
attentio regarder l'affrontement fondant
quip affrontera le français franck
l'époque
non on regarde encore franck telle
attention on est sur du jeu france
affronte c'est un 9/9/9 nord regardez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas français
c'est une colle et c'est que vous savez
qui c'est ça les rend non je vois que ça
mais si on est féministe et nicki minaj
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui connaît que fallu donc pas du tout
adapté je connais c'est peut-être froch
ou pas français mais en même temps ça
c'est qui c'est et enfin un dernier
grand coup pas franck tu as des couilles
de franco merci à prendre du galon voire
pas du tout